you know what they say those who pill
together kill together no one in all of
human history has ever said that Lia
this has been such an insane ride I've
loved every single episode and we're
getting in for the two-hour finale what
can fans expect well they can expect a
lot of craziness I think a couple more
murders and then the killer reveal in
the final hour I think it's been such an
incredible season Ryan Brad and Ian
really did it again with such an amazing
show and I think that the finale is just
probably our best yet I've never been
happier in my whole life shanell sasai
can hold her hair back now a perch nice
we've got so many great Hester isms what
has been your favorite line of the
season attack my crack Oh what I can't
feel like I can't even say it like it's
not really exact but even when I say and
I kind of flush you know obviously
coming from so many seasons of doing
Glee and getting to play Rachel Berry
which was such an amazing opportunity as
an actor you know I think that there
definitely is an issue with people
having difficulty seeing you play
someone else after being a part of a
show for such a long time but I think
that once the attack my crack line
happened I think that it wasn't an issue
anymore come on
I'm sure this house has an amazingly
romantic basement now that we've gotten
to know Hester and know the full
psychosis of this character what do you
think would happen if Hester and Rachel
were to come face-to-face I think that
anybody that Rachel doesn't have to
compete singing with she will definitely
treat a little bit easier so that's a
good start
other than that I I don't really think
that they would know what to do with one
another but they're both very determined
that that they've been extreme
determination so I'm sure if you put
those two together to get something done
it would happen with great success
you